[Music]
hi my name's anna and today i'm cooking
for you kotolette or crummed chicken
and it's my mother's recipe so i hope
you really like it my mother is from
calabria it's right down the bottom of
italy my cousin's daughter decided that
she wanted the traditional recipes so
that they could be passed down to future
generations so what she did was with her
mother she sat with her grandmother and
she wrote down all the recipes and while
her grandmother wasn't looking
her mother had measuring cups because
italian mamas and nonna's do not
measure it's everything's by a handful
or by eye
so now i'm coating the chicken breasts
in flour
and then in the egg wash mixture and
lastly in the breadcrumb and parmesan
mixture make sure that they're well
coated
so that when you fry them they get a
really really nice color on them i'm
going to be using a combination of olive
oil and butter to fry the chicken it
will give it a really nice golden color
the oil and the butter has got to be
very very hot and it won't take long to
fry them at all this is something i
learned from mum and not all calabrians
do it mainly they use olive oil but mum
just found that using a little bit of
butter just made it a little bit better
so i do it the way my mum does it so we
tweak recipes a little bit too they've
been handed down from the generations
from calabria we tweak them a little bit
and i would imagine the same thing is
done over here as well
[Music]
it's a really tasty dish but the
tastiness is in what you put in it which
is love like with any cooking
[Music]
buonisimo
my name's chris nistrini and i'm making
my grandmother's chicken parmesan the
uniqueness of this is it's usually
brought down through the ages and
basically from
my family there's certain
pieces like what we're doing here that
will actually differentiate it from
another families even one across the
street in italy
their sauce their chicken parmesan
theirs their food is different
in small ways than another family's
which is the uniqueness of the italian
cooking
so we use a little wine for the eggs and
we use
a little wine for the cook
adding wine to the eggs it adds a little
bit of a base
for the egg plus the wine flavor i
really like and it was also something
that my grandmother did every saturday
after baseball the whole family got
together over grandma's house and we
basically had a family lunch and dinner
so i was fascinated with grandma's
cooking because it was incredible and
i watched i just watched and listened
and she did things so naturally that's
why i don't stress out when it comes to
cooking
and another good use for the wine
and check your oil
if it splatters like that it's ready my
grandmother felt that the actual sauce
the tomatoes themselves were a little
boring
so in order to create a bit more of a
base she created that layered process
which ultimately creates a more robust
flavor for the sauce there's olive oil
there's white wine there's chicken stock
and then ultimately um the herbs so
various palermo or sicilian oriented or
the red peppers obviously the garlic
and then bay leaf and some love you
layer that base and then you just reduce
it so it intensifies the flavors
the line shows you when
the the sauce is
thick enough to be able to incorporate
into the tomato sauce without making it
too loose larimo is in the southern part
of italy they call it the boot
or the soccer ball on the boot southern
italian cooking has more uniqueness from
normal northern italian cooking because
of its impact from the the way it was
conquered not conquered so it has a lot
of influence from basically africa and
those african influences are spiciness
palermo cooking or southern italian
cooking is generally more spicy than
northern italian cooking i think food
creates the base of any nationality you
know your memories your
really the substance of your family as a
whole is connected to not only the
heritage but the family recipes and
in some cases they're guarded they're
protected in other cases
the new generation
becomes incredibly intimidated from it
so my suggestion would be to ultimately
enjoy it try to take that base that your
grandma created and make it your own
you'll start the new tradition
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you